people who spend the most money with us
and stay with us the longest are the
ones who are the most pre-sold and
coming to us and so what we did was he
injected multiple long-form pieces of
content into the sales process itself so
we'd Force everybody to consume two long
form pieces of content to make them just
like the people who spend the most money
and stayed the longest on top of that we
started outputting more content specific
to the struggles that they said in the
surveys so each of those pain points we
started making much more content around
solving each of those things and so that
gave my sales team a sales or value
cheat sheet that they could give to
customers to consume so that we could be
even more laser targeted and showing our
expertise that we really knew how to
solve their problems if you have to sell
really hard it's the result of poor
branding you don't have enough Goodwill
you haven't provided enough value in
advance and so the easiest thing to sell
more is provide more value before you
ask and this way you can manufacture
that Goodwill